et là on y va on va être en retard
génial j'ai pas reporter cette jupe
depuis le collège
ça va être beau c'est moi et là et lui
c'est mon meilleur ami la couleur se
plaît pas on est amis depuis notre
naissance pour que ça fonctionne on a
établi une liste de règles
règle numéro 10 ne jamais partager nos
secrets avec d'autres personnes règle
numéro 9 noah le grand rire de lui il
est trop canon mais intouchable depuis
quand est ce à repousser et règle numéro
10 ne jamais jamais enfreindre la règle
numéro 9
tu as encore un peu de bave au coin de
la porte
je conseille des élèves nous a demandé
nos idées pour le gala aujourd'hui vous
pouvez nous dire si flynn fera partie
des volontaires
il est très bien partie des volontaires
je vous le promets pinet toujours ok
pour le stand alors tu veux bien venir
au stade habib où tu peux toujours rêver
génial c'est vrai que t'as aucune
expérience avec les mac torta jamais eu
de petit copain qu'est ce que ça peut te
faire
je raccompagne égaré ou sinon je monte
pas là dessus je suis pas une de ces
nanas que tu finis par choper sortent
pas tout avec moi reconnaît qu'il doit y
avoir 95 % d'entre elles que je finis
par choper
[Musique]
elmer
je crois que tu as reçu un message tu
veux regarder pousser livre un nouvel
admirateurs
[Musique]
j'ai vu devant moi qui pensais que tu me
considérais juste comme la meilleure
copine relou de tout il ya de ça aussi
[Musique]
est ce qu'il se passe quelque chose
entre vous
on le tient personnes d'accord en tout
cas pas donc je le dise ali
[Musique]
j'ai pour moi vous avez rien de plus
important que de suivre les rideaux
mais dans la vie approché mesdemoiselles
et messieurs on peut soit suivre les
règles soient suivre son coeur
[Applaudissements]
je viens juste récupérer ton achat
contre salies chérissent le moment
oublie pas concert samedi soir
j'habitais les vans shérif fais-moi
plaisir s'il te plaît soit sympa avec
elle à elle a un faible pour toi
[Musique]